all right it is time for drew's news
your daily trip to the news forest to
forage for good news mushrooms
and with me at the desk best pilot in
the biz ross madness
hi everybody hi guys
guess what else is happening rossi what
there's bridgerton news oh my gosh i
know i wish we had our veils and our
accoutrements tiaras um our favorite
dreamy and steamy show
is back on netflix this friday well
took you long enough
it has been a long time coming and
stylish reports that the director julie
julianne robinson says what makes their
sex scene so different is she shot them
from the female gaze
for example she took that age-old scene
that we've all been seeing a dude laying
in a bed admiring a gorgeous woman's
body and
flipped the script on it letting daphne
sit back and admire the duke in the buff
it wasn't just daphne by the way
and i loved it i love that they're
shooting this from like flipping the
scritch from the the female point of
view and like focusing on like let's
objectify the men a little bit and hello
you know who's watching bridgeton the
gays and the girls so thank you
if you're a die hard for dirty dancing
well it is time to pack your bag oh my
god by the way anyone remember
kellerman's in the movie of course hello
well travel and leisure reports that you
can now stay in the same resort where
johnny and baby fell in love
me up true that's right
the movie's set at the kellerman's
institute in the catskills but the real
resort is in the blue ridge mountains of
virginia and all spring and summer you
can go on a dirty dancing weekend
complete with a movie themed scavenger
hunt and dance lessons and maybe someone
will like throw you up in the air and
hold you there yes please um ross do you
have hungry eyes for this oh yeah you
did ah
thank you i remember it was like one of
the first movies my mom goes i'm not
gonna let you watch that till i watch it
and then she was like do you wanna watch
it with me because it was it was so good
remember i carried a watermelon speaking
of crimes on tinder the toronto sun
reports a woman recently found out that
it violates tinder law to appear as
a
dot dot dot
clown
jess harkin got kicked off the app for
posing in clown makeup the thing is
she's a professional clown and her real
name or no her clown name is kazoo
and she just wanted to find love and
maybe another clown out there to match
up with and tinder claim that she was
violating their
terms of use i cannot
believe that you can be a tindler
swindler but not a clown yeah she
appealed and got her profile back so she
showed herself
in her outfit for work if she was a chef
and showed her in a chef hat right
this is who she is
she's a client and honestly aren't there
people who do up their instagram so much
with so much makeup that it's like a
clown it's just that their face is not a
clown face that's some good shape that's
some good shade debris that is yes
because so many people be wearing
too much makeup
where is the line
anymore can't be a clown on tinder
would you date a clown
i think i have yeah
we have a psa for anyone who's about to
take their passport photo yep how do i
know this well i just tried to upload my
new passport photo and i got a message
that said my photo was rejected
and the reason why was the smile was
detected look at her
i look too happy you do they rejected my
photo
and here is my fully approved passport
photo
can you believe this
does anyone know that you are not
allowed to smile in a passport photo
raise of hands who knows this
oh everybody
well
in your defense i only know this because
they told me stop smiling when i got the
picture taken why is it hello we're
literally going into other countries we
don't want to do it smiling like
i'm friendly hello but like
what's the difference it's still me
kimmy
um well okay so everybody now knows
no smile
welcome to the country
[Music]